so yesterday donald trump did his first
press briefing since the republican
national convention the first press
press briefing since the shootings over
the weekend it was insanely insane i
don't know any other way to describe it
it was a veritable
historic house of horrors uh let's just
get right into the clips now as you know
one of trump's supporters shot and
killed two people in kenosha wisconsin
and then we also had a trump supporter
shot in portland and trump comes out and
he says i want to give you an
update about left-wing violence in the
united states take a look
vaccine very rapidly in record time
i also want to provide an update on
left-wing
political violence that we're seeing in
democrat-run cities
under my administration federal law
enforcement is working with state and
local authorities
all over the country to comb through
hours of video track down rioters
looters and arsonists and bring them
to justice we've just come so before we
go any further
i know many of you know this just give
me 30 seconds to remind you
most politically based violence in the
united states is right wing
period the anti-defamation league has
studied this for a long time their
latest report from 2018
says 50 of 50 people killed in 2018 were
killed by
right-wing political extremism 78
percent were right uh white supremacists
sixteen percent were anti-government
extremists four percent were in
cell extremists and one guy was an
islamist extremist
remember i i think islamic extremism
rightly should be considered right
wing because it is really not i mean
listen
if you take religion to that level and
believe religion should be law
and that people should die over it that
is not a left-wing belief i've ever seen
but that was one guy okay so maybe it
was 49 out of 50 according to the adl
csis has identified that the
overwhelming majority of violence from
extremists in the u.s comes from white
supremacists
anti-government small government
extremists
including militias and so-called
sovereign citizens groups
uh the center for investigative
reporting looked at this
from 2008 to 2016 they found that out of
a hundred they found 115
right wing terror incidents 63
islamist inspired terror incidents and
19 left-wing incidents
overwhelming violence is from the right
and then lastly the national consortium
for the study of terrorism
maintains these profiles in
radicalization
and they have found that radicalized
individuals since 1948
are 40 percent far-right 25 percent
islamist 17 percent far left
and 18 single-issue folks who could be
anywhere on the on the political
spectrum or outside of it so
don't ever allow yourself to be
distracted the vast majority of
political violence
is right wing donald trump also claims
without evidence
that left-wing protesters have killed a
lot of people
in america we will never surrender to
mob rule because
if the mob rules democracy is indeed
dead
the reason we're continuing to see
violence in left-wing cities today is
that
liberal politicians mayors prosecutors
and judges are
refusing to enforce the law and put the
riders in jail these are riders these
are dangerous people
these are killers they kill a lot of
people donald trump given the
opportunity to condemn the pro-trump
protesters
that were shooting paintballs at people
driving vehicles into people pepper
spraying people over the weekend
donald trump says well those were
peaceful protesters and he answers
cnn reporter caitlin collins by saying
that her supporters
her supporters her supporters are the
ones being violent the question on
coronavirus but first
you were just criticizing joe biden
saying he didn't mention the far
left or antifa during his speech today
you said you wanted to talk about
left-wing political violence yeah but i
noticed you did not mention
that your supporters were also in
portland this weekend firing paintball
guns at people
some form of pepper spray so do you want
to also take this chance to condemn what
your supporters did
well i understand they had large numbers
of people that were supporters but that
was a peaceful protest
and paint is not and paint is a
defensive mechanism paint is not bullets
your supporters your supporters and they
are your supporters indeed
shot a young gentleman
who and killed him not with paint
but with a bullet and i think it's
disgraceful
these people they protested peacefully
they went in very peacefully
and i'll tell you what they're
protesting they're protesting when they
turn on television
or read whatever they may be reading and
they see
a city like chicago where 78 people were
shot
and 13 died or a city like new york
where the crime rate has gone through
the roof
or a city like portland where the the
entire city is
ablaze all the time and the mayor says
we don't want any help from the federal
government
when these people turn that on and they
see that they say
this is not our country this is not our
country that was a peaceful protest
totally
caitlyn collins supporters what what
does that even mean
and donald trump received a follow-up
question
he ended up defending kyle rittenhouse
the 17 year old supporter of his
who has now been charged with homicide
after killing two people
in kenosha wisconsin take a look
go ahead mr president
it was
[Music]
that was an interesting situation you
saw the same
tape as i saw and uh he was
trying to get away from them i guess it
looks like and he fell
and then they very violently attacked
him and it was something that we're
looking at right now and it's under
investigation but
uh i guess he was in
very big trouble he would have been he
probably would have been killed but
it's under it's under investigation do
you think private citizens should be
taking i'd like to see law enforcement
take care of everything
i think everything should be taken care
of law enforcement but again we have to
give
our cops back our police back their
dignity the respect they're very
talented people
and of course donald trump continuing to
insist
that joe biden won't condemn violence
now
joe biden gave a speech yesterday where
he condemned all violence he actually
said
if it's from the right or from the left
i condemn all violence
it was it couldn't have been more direct
and simple
and donald trump who does not condemn
all violence
simply repeats biden won't condemn it
concerns though that it could
exacerbate tensions and increase
violence do you give any
consideration well it could also
increase enthusiasm
and it could increase love and respect
for our country
and that's why i'm going because they
did a fantastic job as soon as i called
and told them let's go the whole problem
stopped that was what success
now of course um donald trump here
he could be right he might not be when
he says that
the tensions and the unrest could
increase voter enthusiasm we heard from
kellyanne conway yesterday
she said very clearly trump believes the
unrest will help him
maybe it will maybe it won't i think
there is a case to be made
that a more systemic analysis like that
done by
election predictor alan lichtman may be
more accurate from the standpoint of
saying
systemically how is the economy doing
these major kind of qualitative factors
are more important in influencing the
election
it's not inconceivable that on the
margins in the two months between now
and the election
maybe unrest will activate more of the
donald trump base
and get them to vote it won't
necessarily change people's minds but it
might activate
certain parts of the electorate i don't
know
lastly donald trump was asked not to go
to kenosha wisconsin a reporter said did
you
consider listening to the requests of
the governor and the mayor and trump
says nah
mr president um are you giving any
consideration for
did you give any consideration to the
governor and mayor's request
not to come to kenosha tomorrow no
because kenosha was something we did a
good job when the governor didn't want
us there
he didn't want uh the national guard as
you know
he was very reluctant but i give him
credit because
ultimately he said yes and as soon as he
said yes the problem ended
but i have to see the people that did
such a good job for me and we're meeting
with
numerous people and we have tremendous
support in the state of wisconsin
so will this work that's what i want to
hear from you about
will trump trying to foment and then
capitalize on
unrest sort of playing arsonist and
firefighter
is this a strategy that you believe on
balance
in the net net net will be helpful for
trump going into the election
or not uh i want to hear from you we'll
have continued coverage of this
on our instagram page at david pakman
show
real quick i want to tell you about our
sponsor magic spoon
who have done something awesome they've
taken all of our favorite sugary
childhood cereals
that we know we shouldn't eat anymore
and turn them into something you can
actually feel good about eating as an
adult
there's four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted and blueberry
they taste great they're crunchy they're
sweet like you would expect this type of
cereal to be
but it's perfect for a ketogenic diet
because one bowl has only
three net carbs 12 grams of protein it's
sugar free
gluten free grain free soy free
once our team tried magic spoon for the
first time we actually ended up emailing
magic spoon back and saying can you send
us
more boxes send more samples they've
been a big hit
with david pakman show staffers and
magic spoon
knows how delicious their cereal is
because if you don't like it they'll
refund all of your money no questions
asked
and you'll get free shipping when you go
to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman that's
p-a-k-m-a-n